joining me now is texas lieutenant
governor dan patrick who was grabbing
the mic to speak
when mr o'rourke had this outburst dan
um first of all uh you know our our deep
deepest prayers and condolences to
everyone in texas and the people of
uvalde who are suffering so greatly
tonight we have to say that before we
say anything else
what happened today
at that press conference
was so despicable but from your
perspective tell us what happened
yeah so when i sat down
uh i noticed that we were in the large
auditorium in the high school i noticed
that beto was in the second row on the
end seat
and i literally could see him leaning
forward almost like he was getting to
pounce
and so i
but i didn't imagine i could see maybe
he was going to stand up and ask a
question at some point or make a
statement but i
could never imagine that on this day
when we were there to not only
disseminate information and learn more
but were there to
be with these families
that he would pull such a political
stunt
you know i thought laura and i said in
my comments after he finally left
that can't we have just one day
one week
one month of us all coming together
for these children that's not a
political stunt not partisan politics
where's our humanity and what we found
out is that o'rourke was more interested
in his political ambitions than he was
about these families and that's what i
think was really
the tragedy of his behavior
it showed he really didn't care about
these people and that's what we were
there for that's what governor abbott
said myself and the others who spoke
well he certainly couldn't have thought
dan
that
what he was doing was bringing comfort
to the families or
really nothing was going to advance the
narrative of safety or concern
this was first and foremost an act of
political selfishness
period absolutely
absolutely and well planned by the way
he came again i saw him out of the
corner of my eye and i was wondering
what he was up to he had a right to be
there but
total political selfishness and and and
so here we are laura
um and this is not by the way what
texans expect in a leader to behave like
this particularly in this day he could
have had a press conference outside if
he wanted he could have brought this up
at some other time and some debate or
some issue but not this day it was just
offensive to these children who died in
these teachers and by the way laura i
found out in talking to one of the
school
employees one of the teachers who was
killed was found dead laying on top of a
student as i as i said yesterday when i
was was interviewed we would hear
stories about these heroic teachers and
the heroism of these two teachers in
that classroom and the law enforcement
um uh let me laura i've been through
a lot in texas we've had a lot of
shootings in texas a lot of disasters
but whenever it's children laura as you
said with your own i have children
grandchildren it gets to the core of who
we are as a country and and laura
so i i just uh to for him to do that
today and for us to even spend five
minutes talking about him i just dismiss
him and i think america and texas
dismissed him today quite frankly
lieutenant governor back to the question
i asked lieutenant oliveiras
about the point of entry of the school i
mean if if someone is hell-bent on
maiming and destroying they will figure
out a way to do it probably right
but if there if there was and we'll find
out more but if there was a side
entrance or a back door that was open
that can't happen at any school in the
country it just can't happen
those have to be secured and a front
door has to be the only point of entry i
mean we've said this before and i think
you and i have talked about it before
yeah we did four years ago
last week was our shooting at santa fe
and the day of the shooting that was the
first thing i recognized is that our
schools were not really protected the
way they should be and we've put in a
tremendous amount of money over 100
million dollars in trying to give
schools the tools to fortify their
schools it's not always as simple as you
sound but
as you say or people say but our
elementary and middle schools for sure
are not that big where we can control
the exit you should have one way in one
way out every door should be locked had
he and i went up to where that door was
today i walked i walked that area uh had
that door been locked and he had taken a
few more minutes to look for another
entrance he may have been stopped before
getting into the school so it's really
important we do that in our high schools
we're even going to have to think about
how we redesign our high schools because
our high schools are so large laura that
one entrance doesn't work but we've got
to address that issue but laura
i i if i can i just come back to this
laura this problem is a
much larger problem um than
the infrastructure the gun issue the
mental health issue this is a
and all those are important
but at the end of the day laura
we are in a sick society
where we are at each other's throats all
the time
he showed it today everywhere you look
we are just whether it's on the internet
um whether it's in any walk of life
people are just at each other every day
and we have to ask ourselves who we are
and i believe we're a nation of godly
people and godly people
uh
need need to pray we've got to make
changes and people
we go we've got to make changes
second chronicles 7 14 laura everyone
should read tonight go to the middle of
the bible turn right second chronicles 7
14 christians have to pray for god to
heal our land and we have to take a
stand if there are some people in this
country who are not believers that's
fine i respect their right not to
believe but for those of us who are
christians we need to take hold of our
country and we do that through prayer
you cannot change the culture of a
country without changing the character
of the people and you just cannot change
character without changing a heart and
you can't do that without turning to god
thank you laura
all right lieutenant governor great to
see you tonight thank you so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else